المقاومه الفلسطينيه تواجه اسرائيل في
الظل تعلن حركه حماس ان بيدها اربعه جنود
اسرائيليين لا تفصح مصيرهم بينما تقول
اسرائيل انهم اما جثث او مدني من تعترف
اسرائيل بانهم جنود في جيشها شاؤول ارون
[موسيقى]
بالجيش الاسرائيلي وعمل في لواء النخبه
على الحدود مع قطاع غزه شارك في الحرب على
القطاع عام 2014 وفيها تم اسره على يد
مقاتل كتائب القسام تقول اسرائيل انهارون
قتل لكن عائلته ترفض قبول هذه الروايه منذ
اثري وحتى الان لم تقدم حركه حماس اي
معلومات خاصه به الجندي يحمل رتبه ملازم
ثاني في الجيش الاسرائيلي اسره مقاتل
القسام في منطقه رفح اثناء حرب 2014
ارتكبت اسرائيل مجزره في رفح ردا على اسر
جولدن قتلت فيها اكثر من 100 فلسطينيه
بينهم اطفال ونساء
بعد انتهاء حرب 2014 باسابيع قليله اجتاز
افرا منغستون السياج الفاصله بين اسرائيل
وشمالي قطاع غزه واختفت اثاره ولد من جست
في اثيوبيا ثم هاجرت عائلته الى اسرائيل
وهو في عمر خمس سنوات واقامت في مدينه
عسقلان تقول وعائلته انه مضطرب النفسيه
وتم تسريحه من الجيش اتهمت عائلته الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مرات عديده بتعمد اهمال ابنها
لاسباب العنصريه لانه من اصول الاثيوبيه
قالت كتائب القسام بعد اعتقاله بخمس سنوات
ان اسرائيل لم تطالب باعاده من جسته من
خلال الوسطاء الذين تحدثوا معها بشان
المحتجزي
الاسير الرابع هو هشام السيد فلسطيني ومن
النقب يحمل الجنسيه الاسرائيليه تقول
المصادر الاسرائيليه انه دخل قطاع غزه
وبيع عام 2015 عبر ثغره في السياج الفاصل
بين اسرائيل وشمالي القطاع تقول مصادر
فلسطينيه انهد دراسته الثانويه وتطوع
للخدمه في الجيش الاسرائيلي عام 2008
وسرحت العام نفسه لانه غير مناسب للخدمه
ما ظهر حتى الان بشكل رسمي مقطع فيديو
نشره القسام اواخر يونيو الماضي للجندي
الاسرائيلي اسير هشام السيد على سرير
المرض وتظهر بطاقته العسكريه
اسرائيل قبل ذلك باسابيع قليله حصلت
الجزيره عبر برنامج ما خفي اعظم على تسجيل
صوتيا لاحد الجنود الاسرى دون الافصاح عن
هويته يكون فيديو منجستو هو الاول من حيث
ظهور الاسير بالصوت والصوره ما في يد
المقاومه ورقه مهمه بالنسبه الى
الفلسطينيين قائمه طويله من الاسرى احياء
وامواتا مئه محكومين بالمؤبدات منهم منذ
ما قبل اتفاق اوسكو عام 93 وعشرات نساء
والاطفال والمرضى اكثر من 370 جثه لشهيد
تتمسك اسرائيل بهذه الجثث لاستخدامها في
مفاوضات التبادل هؤلاء الاسرى احياء
وشهداء ليس مجرد ارقامه بالنسبه الى ذويهم
كذلك تقول المقاومه الفلسطينيه